all right ronnie
yeah ronnie uh where'd you grow up where
you from originally i'm originally from
bakersfield which is oil dell i was born
and raised there with my four sisters
and we grew up right there was all born
in kerr medical center
how was how was your childhood we ate
we had nice clothes to wear to school
and we had nice things
my dad was always a hard worker they
just didn't want to hire him because
they came from ireland him
my mom and they treated us like blacks
and about 12 13 years down the line
i was already locked up but uh
what were you locked up for a murder two
counts
what age thirteen i killed my best
friend
and i killed lose for well how'd you do
that or why'd you do that
i had a gun back then and i was a big
dealer at 10 years old i'm as tall as i
am now
and uh got the house raided six times
my dad said that's enough you got to
quit doing that
i was 13 when i first went in
to get locked up they gave me three more
years until i was old enough to go to
paso robles
and then they were killings on the field
every other week
guards were dying left and right uh
guards were getting raped
uh it was just bad
inmates were getting raised so you did a
total of how many years probably about
28 years then
wow how old are you now i'm uh 68.
and uh so you got out at roughly what
age
25 and it's been closed down
ever since due to all the killings and
lawsuits and stuff
so where'd your life go after after you
got out i got married
stayed married a long time
and uh then i am old enough i went to
nom
i got drafted uh
second day or no third day i did a
second
tour and i seen my friend jumped up and
he got hit
five or six times it killed him
instantly
and then i jumped up took three bullets
two went all the way through me
one still in my spine
stuck in my spine they can't take it out
i'll go paralyzed
and you've been down here on skid row
for how long
four months now and i rent the motel
because i get
checks when i ain't giving it all away i
rent the motel
for me and another friend of mine that's
my ken
uh for 13 1400 a month
are drugs a part of your life now
when i got out in um i had a 3 000
dollar habit for heroin and i was doing
coke too
and i was drinking four of the five
bottles of vodka
not the big big ones but the other tall
ones
and a case and a half two cases of beer
and it went on for 19 to 20 years
and my dad was helping me and i was
married but he was
helping me get back through it and they
had me on yellow jackets
from the hospital and i would take them
they was
better than reds i would take them and i
felt good
i was clean for like four months and i
had a convention to go to it was a comp
cop convention and i went in the
bathroom and i slammed i was clean
and soon as i got on stage walked on
stage i said a few things
and that was it oh deep but when i was
in
juvenile hall i was always on red tag
i tried to make my bed it wasn't good
enough to come out and watch
hour and a half of tv at night time at
seven o'clock
and then we go to bed at 8 30
and that went on for a year and a half
you know so today you're using still
no you're not you're clean i'm clean
yeah
but uh i was in bad shape i'm not gonna
lie it took me
five years to walk again
five years
and i can't have sex that's why my wife
left me i had two kids tasha and terry
jr
she left me she tried to come back seven
eight years later
after i was out and i couldn't have sex
all i can do is was the tongue
she said that won't work it's all right
that does bother me but i tried
to bypass it because i can understand i
can't
it don't get harder nothing no more it
won't go up
uh i understand what she's saying
that's from one of your injuries yeah
the bullet in my
spine yeah but it's german it's that
long
you have a good relationship with your
kids very good
my daughter's 50 and my son
is uh two years younger than her
and today you're you're using or you're
clean i'm clean you're clean
yeah and how does this affect you
emotionally all everything you've been
through
it's hard it's it's hard
you know you get depressed i assume
sometimes i do they give me all them
pills every
month because they got a bullet in me
and i got brain cancer
and uh what you do sometimes i don't
take them
they're value morphine uh
and uh yellow jack
not yellow jacks but uh yellow something
and uh the lotus
i just give them away sometimes i don't
give them all away i say here and i'll
give them eight to ten of them
and the the morphines go for
25 35 a piece and i'll give them 10
just free looking back at your life
what's your biggest regret well i got my
education my dad made sure
that
i minded i minded my dad real good i was
just a heavy drug
dealer
how'd you get involved in drugs so soon
so really my brother-in-law
i was about six seven he'd have me
hitting the bong
uh do a little line he had put on my
tongue
and i was seven eight years old and that
led to dealing
that led to dylan and using a lot i was
slamming at 10 years old i'm clean
i ain't got no thing i got it in my
pocket where is everything's clean
i just got cancer and i got uh the spoil
of them
[Music]
do you have friends yeah you do that's
great yeah
that helped you a lot well they help me
a lot when i need
something but i never ask them for
another
i mean they're all drug addicts
yeah most most people down here are yeah
drinking or drug addicts
you're not tempted to start drinking
again or using
there for a minute last month i ain't
gonna lie i went back to old dell
and i drunk uh three or four bottles of
vodka
and i shot about an eight ball of a
crank and it's excellent because my
people make it and uh i smoked a bunch
of weed and then we had barbecue
barbecue lasted like four or five days
it was good was the best time of your
life
this time my life
when i first got married
that was the and i already knew her she
uh
was my sister's babysitter and i was in
paso robles
and they called me out
and uh they got the food ready and stuff
she kissed me
and i had gate passes then after
13 years and we got to go to pismo
and we was in my mom dad's van and i
asked her hey can i get some she said
hell yeah you can
where are we going to do it at so i
asked my dad and mom i said do it in
there
so i went in there and did it got out
six months later after that she was
already pregnant
yeah that's great yeah
what have you learned about life from
all this i learned a lot
there's a lot in life we don't know yet
about
but they know where we're at it's
amazing
and it's very true if you know
when you say they they know where we're
at what do you mean
well
i believe in extraterrestrial but i
believe in jesus too
jesus made extraterrestrial it's not
only us
and me my wife his wife my other best
friend and his wife
therefore we lost about 13 hours
and we was going up to camp owens cabin
do some skiing
and and hunting was going to get us a
deer
or two and uh
i seen this light and it was big this
thing was like 20 30
football fields it was huge
and i said stop the car randy we was on
the freeway going up
sarah mountains he stopped my wife and
all the other girls started crying and
it was big
i could have hit it with a rock that's
how close it was
and i said man i told my best friend man
if i had a gun right now i'd blow it out
of the air
it beamed us up and we was butt
butt-necked sitting
on this table and they did some weird
[ __ ] to us
i mean it was weird testing us
can you recall this you remember this
yeah were there drugs involved
no no we probably had a beer or two a
piece and that was
it not even that what are you afraid of
what do you worry about at this point in
your life i worry about my kids but they
they do good terry junior and tasha do
real good
i worry about them though and they're
clean
they don't want to be like me and their
mom
[Music]
uh my daughter drinks
five six fifteen hundred dollar
champagne
i got out one time i saved from license
plates about
100 something checks so i had a couple
thousand on them
she said will you buy me an expensive
bottle of wine i said yeah how much is
it
she said you ain't got that much money
on you i said how much
is it she said it's a lot of money
couple thousand easy
she said can you afford 250 and i said
yeah i give her 250.
she brought it back she opened it she
poured me a cup that big and that big
around i drunk it it lit
me up and i didn't think it would do
that but it did
champagne that's what it was champagne
all right ronnie thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem i wish you
the best of luck
i thank you thank you so much thank you
to sir
have a good day i thank you so much
you